sharon osbourne is speaking out after
holly robinson pete's claim last week
that the 68 year old said she was quote
too ghetto to appear on the talk
i think that we put ourselves out there
that we
are not perfect by far we are not the tv
personality took to twitter on saturday
to deny
pete's recent claims writing that she
did not get pete fired from the talk
in 2011 and adding that she did not say
she was quote to ghetto i didn't not get
on with holly on the show but there was
definitely an undercurrent between us
but
i i admire i admire her very much she's
a very strong woman
very good woman not only did sharon deny
it
she also shared an email allegedly sent
by pete
one month after she was let go by cbs in
2011
where she allegedly claims that she
misses osborne
quote madly in the email pete also
allegedly wrote that she knew osborne
was quote
in a tough spot before stating that leah
remini who was fired from the show at
the same time as pete
was quote very angry about the situation
pete's alleged email also had negative
things to say about their then co-hosts
julie chen
and sarah gilbert and per the unverified
screenshot osborne shared
pete allegedly wrote that she was being
blacklisted
in the industry after being fired from
the show
the alleged email came to a close with
pete thanking osborne for still allowing
her mom
and daughter to attend america's got
talent in the wake of the drama
after sharing the alleged email sharon
doubled down
tweeting never in my life did i utter
the words that
holly was too ghetto to be on the talk
as well as
not having her fired she also stated in
a previous tweet
i have never had the ability authority
to get anyone fired from the talk
did i agree with what he said
no everybody goes if you support him
then you must be racist because he's
racist
i'm not racist neither is pierce racist
prior to pete's recent claim
osborne received backlash for defending
her friend pierce morgan
on twitter after he quit good morning
britain following his controversial
remarks about meghan markle
i'm sorry i don't believe a word she
says meghan markle
i wouldn't believe it if she read my
weather report someone and the fact that
she's fired up
onslaught against our royal family i
think is contemptible
she then had a pretty heated discussion
about racism with her the talk co-hosts
on air wednesday and i think we should
stop this
and don't try and cry because if anyone
should be crying it should be me
right now i'm talking to a woman who i
believe is my friend
and i don't want anybody here to
to watch this and say that we're
attacking you for being racist
i think that's already sewn osbourne
later took to social media to apologize
to quote
anyone of color that i offended and or
to anyone that feels confused or let
down by what i said
when we kind of give passes or give
space to people
who are who are being who are saying
damaging harmful things
what we're kind of doing is permissing
it and i think that's what people are
reacting to
in response to the controversy p tweeted
that she was quote
mortified watching osborne defend morgan
adding quote
i'm old enough to remember when sharon
complained that i was too ghetto for the
talk
then i was gone pete's allegation was
met with support from her close pal
and beyonce's mom tina knowles lawson
who called pete's claim
quote unbelievable and called out
osborne for being
so wrong and inappropriate in 2012
remini took to twitter to allege that
osborne got her and pete fired from the
daytime talk show in part because she
thought they were quote ghetto
osborne denied the allegation and e.t
previously reached out to cbs for
comment
but in the meantime e.t has learned that
the talk is taking a hiatus for a few
days
while they continue to internally review
last week's heated episode